Yeah, he's just not describing the events that led to the lawsuits
accurately at all. [laughter] >> It's just wild to me that
Hutch got on his phone or started like looking at his other monitor
instead of paying attention to this content. It's so obviously
disingenuous, dude. There's no way. Holy [__] Hutch
is a [__] What is the biggest issue? and the CPS
and the [__] skulls on them. [laughter]
Okay, [music] I'll pull up this this hutch reaction. Oh,
we need a misinformed counter. Oh,
hold on. Should we do something like that?
Okay, there we go. >> I have to say >> there we go.
>> Too much. And I don't like to spend, you know, a whole
lot of time on the internet uh directly going at in a very dramatic
way other creators. Everybody that identifies with this particular
tribe, this online tribe, it seems like none of them are capable
of reflecting on the conduct of the space that they all occupy,
the collective communities of all the content creators. None
of that. I've not seen a single person from that tribe acknowledge
that the level of harassment that was targeted at Ethan and Ela
was completely psychotic or even at minimum just it was bad.
like just
>> I've done I've I've done multiple times that like oh
CPS shouldn't have been called that was wrong that was bad but
the the unfortunate thing that Hutch is doing here is he's trying
to say well that tribe's responsible for it one we don't even
know that right we actually don't that is not proven out the
only times Hutch has ever tried to argue this he has gotten blown
the out in the argument okay
yeah I do believe most people do say the CPS call is bad it's
the lies that go into it that everybody's upset about.
You have to lie about who did it or what you know about it because
you can't just on it on its face acknowledge that well it was
bad. It was an anonymous person and you probably can't blame
anybody specific and it certainly can't just be the fault of
everybody who dislikes you. >> acknowledge that it was
bad. I've not seen a single person regardless of how you feel
about the lawsuits. You should be able to >> so already
wrong. Already wrong. In fact, Hassan specifically, if Hutch
cared to pay attention, Hassan specifically, when it happened,
when the CPS call happened, Hassan said, "There's no excuse for
that. Ethan obviously takes care of his kids. That's insane."
So, Hutch is just lying here. Totally lying. Obviously lying.
Incapable of being correct on anything. This guy acknowledge
that. That went way too far. Way too far. And none of them are
capable of acknowledging that. >> Are there elements of
these dynamics that Ethan genuinely feels like, you know, burned
about and pissed off about? Like, maybe possibly. I feel like
I don't know enough about these interpersonal relationships.
Again, on a personal level, that was the that's hilarious, by
the way. That was like incredible timing. That was the best he
could muster. That was the best he could muster. Like, maybe
maybe he had some problems interpersonally with some of these
other creators. That wasn't the issue. It wasn't interpersonal
relationships that was the issue. It was it was the collective
internet pylon that prompted all these lawsuits um to really
Okay. I Does Hutch not understand
Okay. How How could we do this? Could we say that
every should we treat every person who has ever donated $1 to
an organization that sends money to Israel as though they're
Benjamin Netanyahu?
Should we do that? Does that make sense? Would that be a smart
thing to do, guys? Would that be a fair thing to do? Should we
treat every person who even remotely supports the state of Israel
like they're Benjamin Netanyahu? Like, obviously that is wrong.
Obviously, no. I know you guys are Yes, but unironically. I know
you guys are going to joke about it, but obviously you can't
do that. Obviously, that is like the exact kind of thing that
every autocrat, every authoritarian does. They start saying,
"Well, I don't want anybody I want anybody getting even close
to that, so I'm going to make it so scary to get even to even
tow near that line that I'm just going to punish everyone." Right?
Or something bad happened now. I'm going to act like everybody
who was even remotely critical of me for any reason is responsible
for it. Both of these things are wrong. >> On that front,
what? Like if any of you guys, I don't have kids, but I can I
can just try to imagine having kids and if CPS showed show showed
up at my door and then I saw a bunch of creators like joking
about it and laughing about it, bro, I would probably if I had
even resources, I'd probably do the same thing. Let's be honest.
I'd be very Dude,
I Okay,
I
I don't even know where to start. Did Idubs laugh about CPS being
called? Did Idubs do that? Did Denims do that?
I actually don't know who laughed about CPS being called. Again,
nobody's laughing about CPS being called. If they're laughing,
it's at Ethan crashing out over on everybody,
right? Nobody's laughing about CPS being called or kids being
interviewed. People aren't laughing about that. Yeah, I I get
it. I I am though.
Do you guys like being such like weird sheep? Like unironic black
sheep. Sorry, two people had to go, "Oh, I laughed about it."
Even though they didn't. Even though they don't. They don't actually.
It's weird. It's weird >> Pisses me off.
>> Stupid chatter. whole thing makes this tended to ruling
in Denim's favor about all of this. What makes me happy about
this with joy is like look, no matter what problem you have with
any of these people personally or politically, whatever, you
cannot be using this as an opportunity to destroy internet content
creation and uh reaction content, commentary content. I don't
care how up your own ass you are. I don't care how psycho you
are. I don't It's not that Ethan had like a personal issues with
these streamers or that that they had >> Yes, it is that
it's precisely that he had personal issues with these streamers.
Jesus >> political differences. He's leaving out the most
crucial context as to what prompted these lawsuits. I'm not sure
how to mention >> what's the most crucial context that
some person somewhere on the internet possibly somebody in real
life called
and we have no idea what really happened there. Hutch, by the
way, tried arguing this one time, got completely
annihilated by Pisco and cried about it. Okay? Or mentally ill
you are. You cannot be using your millions of dollars and you
cannot be using your platform to sue and go after uh other creators
simply for the sin of reacting to your content, good or not.
>> And let's not forget, okay, let's not
Ethan Klein planned to sue people before CPS was called. You
disgusting bald.
He had the plan to sue people before the CPS call. Idiot. You
would know this if you paid attention to anything >> and
having their own thoughts and opinions about it that you don't
like. There are lots of people who comment on and talk about
it. That's not what the issue is here. My content are there situations
in which I would maybe take legal action if those comments happen
to come from a defamatory place and it was >> disinfo plus
one. Do we count that as misinfo? Yeah, sure. That Hutch is saying
that it's it's actually the CPS call that prompted the lawsuits.
>> All out like complete lies or whatever. I mean, sure,
but that's a different thing than going after somebody just merely
for reacting to your content and claiming and claiming making
the claim that it was stealing. making the claim that this person
is stealing from you by reacting to your content, bro. This is
literally how you got started on the internet, dude. You literally
had your own fair use lawsuit about this same. >> This
guy doesn't even know the particulars of the issue. He doesn't
even know how to unpack this issue. He seems like he's completely
unaware.
Um, this is a symptom of tribalism, by the way. Like, what happens
is you see a bunch of people that are in your tribe and they're
all He's going to perfectly list out why he is completely wrong
on this right now. That is what Hutch is about to do. He's gonna
perfectly lay out the precise reasons he's entirely wrong on
this and then act like that's a normal thing. Act like that's
like totally cool and awesome. >> Going with one particular
take about a thing and then you don't even bother looking up
any particulars about the thing because everyone in your tribe
is all commenting the same thing and so you just repeat that
because you trust them.
And also all the lawsuits were because of the CPS call. That's
what you don't know. And it's because you're in a tribe that
you think that it's because of criticism or jokes, but it's actually
just because of a CPS call. Don't you
>> Don't you know? >> Or you believe that they're
the ultimate arbittors of truth and so you don't even bother
looking into the thing. Um, this is that is like a textbook part
of tribalism. It's one of the really negative aspects about tribalism.
What did he say that was wrong? He's chalking it up to Ethan
sued these people because of uh they didn't like his takes or
he chocked it up to interpersonal drama or difference in politics.
He doesn't even mention the issue the big issue the biggest issues
that happened with Ethan and his family and the secret. >> What
What is What is the biggest issue? What is the biggest issue?
What is the biggest issue? Yes.
Insane. He said it. HE SAID IT. HE SAID IT. He said it. My god.
He said it. Yeah. Ethan was planning to sue them before that
dummy. This dumb man. It's crazy.
Yes, Ethan was planning to sue them before this hutch. Obviously,
he said as much. Are you out of your mind?
>> God, Ethan sued these people of uh they didn't like
his takes or he chocked it up to interpersonal drama or difference
in politics. He doesn't even mention the issue, the big issue,
the biggest issues that happened with Ethan and his family and
the CPS and the skulls and the insane internet pilot. Dude, he
just says it. He just says it. And the best part is he does that
all on the back of a rant about how this is tribalism and how
you never look into the particulars because you just trust the
things people in your tribe say.
That's what that went on for the better part of a year. All because
Ethan didn't want a one-state solution. Essentially, >> the
undisputed purpose of the defendant's live stream is to contest,
criticize, and mock the plaintiff's message, which the courts
have found weighs in favor of fair use due to its transformative
nature. And they even proceed to cite Ethan Klein's case. >> I
feel bad. And I >> surely somebody somewhere very close,
somebody has to point out, well, actually, he was suing already.
He was going to sue before this. >> Regret ever having
platformed you and had you on my own channel on a podcast and
and pushed people in your direction because you you turned around
and ended up doing this. And again, I'm not even talking about
whatever sort of like political or ideological sort of, you know,
disagreements he may have with these individuals or that >> it's
not about that at all. Um, I don't like that he's using copyright
as a bludgeon because that sets a bad precedent, but you can't
pretend Ethan doesn't have a reason for it. I think in the case
of people that were explicitly saying watch it here so you don't
give him a view. That goes in my in my opinion so far beyond
what should be considered fair use. At that point, you are just
like maliciously >> like this this person is just a robot
that has nothing to do with the law.
So I h
it sure sucks that Pisco decided to bow out of all of this cuz
Pisco is the one person who could get conversations with Hutch
and then Hutch would have to actually defend his opinions. Now
P now Hutch doesn't have to talk to anybody. Hutch doesn't have
to talk to anybody who disagrees with him ever. He just gets
to spout off whatever the he wants all the time.
>> Uh trying to like steal someone's content.
Um, that said, again, the one the one lawsuit that I'm kind of
iffy
>> Oh, sorry. Again, uh, misin counter saying that Denims
was saying she wanted to steal confused from Ethan. That's wrong.
Lie. Total lie. >> The the one against Noah. That's the
one where I'm like, well, I don't know. That's going to be tough
to win in court. I feel like the other ones they it was just
they were maliciously
they were so emboldened.
>> Pisco quit living there.
>> Uh, Pisco just doesn't do drama stuff anymore. And they
all everybody involved in these lawsuits from Denims to Noah
to uh uh what's her name? Caseyron to Frogan. They all piled
on
the Ethan
>> Piled on. What does that even mean? Define pylon.
What is What is pylon in this case? >> Over just what should
not have that like Ethan I've said this a million times, but
Ethan and Ela should be natural allies to the online left like/propalestinian
cause. You have these two um individuals.
Why?
That that's not true. Ela Klein. Okay, you could maybe give maybe
in some universe you could say Ethan. You can't say Ela. Ela
is unironically like a to Oh, I should be careful. I should be
careful cuz I do think this could get clipped. Ela Klene is an
ideological Zionist. She is like a brainwashed died in the wool
Israeli Zionist who does not think that Palestinians deserve
anything. I'm sorry. That's just facts.
That's just facts, dude.
It comes out every time she speaks candidly on the issue. Okay?
Maybe she doesn't want a total holocaust of Palestinian Arabs,
but like it's not super far away from that. Okay? And it's not
about her being the raider of Ramala or people in the IDF. It
is just her political opinion. She has a bog standard like possibly
center or possibly even slightly
slightly left of center opinion in Israel. And that includes,
hey, we need to bomb all of southern Lebanon, right? She would
totally support this. It wouldn't even be close. You could see
it come out in their podcast. Man, they are not allies to the
pro Palestine movement. Not even close.
That have a direct tie to Israel that lived in Israel for years.
Ela served in the IDF. And both of them are sympathetic to the
Palestinian cause. They just don't favor a one-state solution.
I mean, they should be natural
Uh, but that didn't happen. They just, you know, they got they
were they were on the receiving end of some of the wildest, most
unhinged
collective pylons literally I've ever seen on the
No, I No. What? What happened to them? They got They got those
skulls shipped to their house and they got a CPS call. There
is at least some reason to believe that that CPS call came from
somebody who worked for them who like unless that's investigated.
Unless there is some police investigation into this and proof
of a police investigation, I don't even believe that they don't
know who it was to tell you the truth. That's me personally,
okay? But they've blamed everybody else for it. I think they've
tried to do this explicitly because they don't want people on
the internet disliking them. They want to make it anathema to
disagree with them or dislike them on the internet. Too bad.
internet. I may have >> go said to the studio, not the
house. I >> unhinged. I I don't know.
>> I don't know where they lie. >> Taiwan's literally
I've ever seen on the >> I may have curly sap with eight
months. Counter argument. Hutch. Do you think your judgment is
skewed from your lack of hair? Maybe that's possible. Jug Runner
with $5. So Ethan is assuming these people because other people
called CPS. He registered the content nuke before the CPS call
even happened. Wait, when did the content nuke come out and when
was the dude dude
dude? That's insane.
That's totally insane. Yeah, it's also Jug Runner every single
time. It's very funny. That's
that he goes on this whole rant about how tribalism prevents
you from looking into any fact, so you just repeat everything
else everybody else says and then he has no idea
when the actual Library of Congress registrations happened and
that they're before the CPS call or before the skulls and before
the
>> The But before the CPS call even happened. Um, wait,
when did the content new come out and when was the the CPS call?
But just bear in mind like the CPS call happened after months
of sustained intense harassment. I think that if you are a content
creator, if you're a streamer, you do have a an obligation to
moderate your channels, moderate your community. Okay. Well,
I mean, I've I've watched Hutch before and see people spam docs
in his chat. I wonder if people have any concern about that.
I've seen Hutch not moderate when Pisco is getting dogpiled by
his chat ever. And in fact, I I do believe the way Hutch's chat
was treating Pisco during one of their last or second last conversations
was about as bad as Ethan Klein was getting treated. I think
it was pretty close.
Um
it started in Hassan's community when they had their little kind
of breakup phase that lasted weeks. It was like post October
7th and um Ethan was expressing concern that there were people
online that were embracing some of the most like virolently anti-semitic
voices and running with the most virolently anti-semitic nonsense.
There were people that were whitewashing uh Hamas, glorifying
Hamas, >> celebrating what happened on October 7th, and
it freaked Ethan out. And that was like the start of the conflict
with Hassan's community.
Yeah, that's that's all it was, man. So Ethan was like, "Hey,
Hassan, I think some people really love Hamas." And Hassan was
like, "Well, I love Hamas and NOW YOU'RE GONE. NOW I WON'T MODERATE
FOR YOU. YOU'RE A ZIONIST."
That's like how that went, guys. Like totally That was all it
was. That was everything.
Um, and then it kind of bled from there.
>> Ethan's community made a Twitch terrorist or Twitch
streamer game and this was when Hassan was defend still defending
him. Yeah. This is the sad thing is Hassan like quite literally
said, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no." Like you like the
CPS call was unacceptable. Hassan was still going out of his
way to defend Ethan long after Ethan was attacking him, attacking
people around him. Like there was a period where Hassan specifically
was holding back. Now you could say the people around Hassan
didn't like Ethan because of these things. And I think that would
be true. But what do you want? You want Hassan to defend Ethan
and not attack Ethan, not say anything about Ethan, and to pull
his community back while Ethan is going like whole hog on him,
trying to get him banned, participating with Dan to get Hassan
banned and to get his income taken away. Like, that's what you
want. That seems a little over the top, man. I don't know. I
What do we expect? It kind of bled out from there. And then all
of a sudden you had all this other commentary from other people
that are kind of like a rung below Hassan
and they were doing nothing to reign in their own communities
and uh you know did they directly orchestrate this or that thing?
No. But they they enabled like a really really ugly thing. >> H
you don't have ads anymore when you cover politics on Twitch.
What what do we talk about enabling a really really ugly thing
>> in my opinion? That's my take on that. Whatever you
feel about the lawsuits, I understand the instinct that Ethan
has to punish people who tried to hurt his family. I understand.
>> He's not trying to punish people who hurt his family.
I'm going to actually count that as misinformation. Again, he
says these people tried to hurt his family. They did not.
They were mocking him. They were criticizing him. They did not
go after his family. You are Denims did not go after his family.
Okay? And that's that's as that's as egregious as anything got
in terms of Hassan's community or his orbiters was Denim's watching
that bad amp up video. That is mostly just quotes from Ethan
Klein and her community had roughly the same reaction to it that
Ethan Klein's community did stand that instinct with 6 months
enable gifts/jwels in YouTube studio. I have some for you. I
don't even know what the you're talking about you. That's not
Jewels. What are you talking about? They're literally using your
platform, literally using these. >> So, what happened here?
Hutch basically got told, well, actually, Ethan was planning
to sue people before the CPS call and he had to he he completely
exploded his brain, started complaining about harassment Ethan
was getting from all like it was totally crazy. They enabled
something horrible. He just didn't engage with the information
that was given to him, right? The information that was given
to him was, "Hey, Hutch, just so you know, CPS was, sorry, CPS
was after Ethan registered the content nuke so that he'd be able
to sue people for statutory damages. He already had his plan
to sue people and Hutch didn't engage with that. He just went
on a rant about how Hassan's communities or communities around
Hassan enabled something terrible. He didn't engage and then
he just goes back to watching the video. these petty disagreements,
your own emotions that you're so tied up in in this situation
to destroy the very industry that we all operate within because
you're mad that you're getting criticized. Are some of those
criticisms unfair and are they coming from like weird termally
on online psychos that are on Reddit or this platform or that
platform? Yeah, I'm sure some of them are. I deal with those
types of people too all the time. But to be going after other
streamers for uhoh uh oh Jugrunner just did the worst possible
thing.
I think I know you think it's all Stark narrative, but the Kilo
video lays the timeline out perfectly. Timelines out perfectly.
I've yet to see anyone dispute it. It convinced me. Unpleas >> or
commenting on your content. And if this lawsuit ended up going
in Ethan Klein's favor, um effectively would have destroyed the
the business model of anybody and everybody doing the same exact
thing, doing the same exact thing, reacting to other content,
commenting on other content. He's just not describing the events
that led to the lawsuits accurately at all. He's leaving out.
>> Do we notice how Hutch got informed of how he was misleading?
He was
He got told this specifically.
He paused. He went on a rant about how Ethan was getting harassed
without without acknowledging or actually responding to what
was being said. And then he just repeated what he was saying
before verbatim
without actually ever updating.
And there are still people in his chat. I believe Missy's there.
I believe Jug Runner's there who are both disagreeing with him.
Right.
And I don't know. I don't know how he does it. That feels crazy
to me. So much crucially important context there. >> Transformatively
critiquing and pulling apart other content that would have created
such an ugly, horrible just um destructive slippery slope. And
you all did you did it over some >> YouTube gifts and jewels
are YouTube's new virtual item system for live streams. Viewers
buy jewels through a
>> got timed out and spend.
>> Hey Graves, what have I lied about? So Missy's asking,
"Did I lie?" This Jay guy said, "You get caught in a lie and
then you double down on it." And Missy says, "I don't think you
know what bad faith is. What do I lie about?" >> Animated
visual effects that appear on screen during a creator creator's
vertical live stream. >> Oh, also we're going to amp up
the misinfo count because Hutch is saying that Fant is not recounting
events correctly or is something up while Hutch has explicitly
avoided getting the information to make himself correct. >> Creators
receive rubies which convert into real earnings.
I am just learning about this. I don't know what the this is.
You did it over some stupid, mindless, petty, emotional, moronic
is literally all you did it for. You didn't do it for any other
reason other than some petty stupid. And I'm glad that Denims
had it ruling. >> I don't think it's I don't think it's
petty. I mean, I think Ethan can be petty.
Uh but I don't think the the lawsuits themselves were an example
of that pettiness. I don't think it was about him being petty.
I think it was about his family and all that stuff. >> No.
and you've been told now by two different people. You've had
super chats about it, multiple super chats about it in fact,
and you refuse to acknowledge them. You literally read them and
then you do this performative like mental reset and don't ever
internalize the >> Your favor not only because you know
>> uh just said Ethan does this for his
His info count goes up. >> Like and respect Denims as a
streamer. Oh, yep. So, Hutch, if Hutch were to watch this, Hutch,
just so you know, one, sometimes I'm a little over the top with
the hate as a part of a character. It's all fun in games, okay?
I'm not actually that I'm not actually hating you right now,
okay? It's okay. You're going to be okay. I don't actually hate
you. You're going to be fine. But if you are watching, watch
the first section of the Kilotonics video. Watch it off stream
if you feel uncomfortable. Okay? and just become aware of the
timeline, how things actually unfolded,
and then come back and comment on this because when you get told
about it repeatedly by your chat, including super chats that
you read, and then you refuse to engage with any of that information,
you look like a propagandist. You look like you are totally disingenuous.
You look like you're incapable of actually discerning fact from
fiction. It's particularly egregious when you talk about tribalism
and how tribalism prevents people from engaging with the facts.
And then you go on to not engage with the facts and take people
who are in your tribe at their word and present their narratives
with no questioning of your own. Okay, just in case Hutch, that's
a little PSA for Hutch, just in case he's watching. >> You
have to stream vertically to get
So that's not going to work. But um uh this would have been
>> So last I checked, Missy asked what did she lie about?
>> Bad for everybody making content on the internet if
this had ruled in Ethan's favor. So I'm just coming on here and
just celebrating this W. for anyone's
content of any person on the internet where they are reacting
to a video or talking about somebody else's video or talking
about some other piece of content somebody made. And I was going
to say, has there even been like an official ruling yet?
Is this thing like done? I feel like it's not right. It's been
seven days and the judge hasn't finalized the verdict, >> incorporated
clips or incorporated a snippet here, a section there, or you
know, reacting to a full video on a stream. It would have been
dunzo. It would have been dunzo. like it would have set legal
precedent that would have allowed any other content creator to
go after a streamer, go after a YouTuber. >> Jug Runner
with $5. I know you think it's all snark narrative, but the Kilo
video lays out the timelines perfectly. I've yet to see anyone
dispute it. It convinced me. Wow. Listen, I'm never going to
watch a video by anybody in that crew, but uh why I just don't
why would you not take information that is correct? Like, could
you imagine
like this is actual MAGA behavior, right? Oh, I'm never going
to read a report from a Democrat.
Like, it's it's unironically just totally brain. It's so embarrassing,
man.
It's so embarrassing, dude. And by the way, he watches. Dude,
should I just drop I should like start reacting to Hutch and
then I should drop a random Kilo clip in the middle of it. Okay,
this is why Kilo should have done some shorts. I told him, "Dude,
cut your stuff. Cut like the main points into shorts so that
you can go and like put it out there and just have content on
your channel, right?" And if I could just play like little clips
from his from his video to show people like, hey, this is this
is what the case is. Hey, this is actually what the case is,
what the timeline is. Be very helpful. Just in the middle. Just
drop it in in the middle. He has to By the way, he's watched
multiple videos from me since that Discord was leaked. Just so
we're clear, right? He has reacted to me multiple times. He is
just lying.
He is totally lying, right? This is objectively just Hutch lying
right now. I'll never watch a video from anyone in that group.
You've watched multiple videos of mine
while not paying attention, not caring, not understanding. You
get the platiner stuff all wrong. You embarrassed
Oh boy. Okay. It's
that's crazy. Uh Hutch misinfo count. I'll never watch anything
from anyone in that group. He's watched several of my videos
since those logs were leaked. The CBS situation, that event
was just one thing that happened in like a 9 to 12 month time
frame of just some of the most unhinged harassment I've ever
seen. >> What was the unhinged harassment?
What was the unhinged harassment? By the way, he's totally he
has internalized that the timeline is wrong and he's stopped
saying CPS right now. He's gone to well, actually, it's just
all of the things. Actually, it's just all of the things, right?
Missy points out that's the genetic fallacy. You you don't accept
information from certain sources. Well, that's kind of broken.
That's kind of brain broken. Hutch. >> Uh all these creators
had to do was like, hey, like you can even acknowledge that you
think Ethan's political takes or Israel takes are bad. You can
you can hang on to that. You don't need to abandon that. But
all they had to do was just say, hey, you know, like it's some
of this is going too far. >> Kilo makes videos that are
meant to convince you of things like that. I'm hoping you didn't
believe it was a neutral third party assessment.
Kilo makes videos that are meant to convince you of things like
what? Like
that like I sorry
I I said
well I said that what I should say actually is just like yeah
that's all video essays. Have you seen a video essay that is
not actually attempting to convince you of something?
Wait what? Yes. It's trying to convince you of something which
is hey these lawsuits uh basically Ethan Klein's timeline for
these lawsuits and his reasoning for these lawsuits have been
lied about extensively.
And when he says it's to protect his family, he is lying to you.
He is just making it up.
>> Which it obviously was and they didn't do that. They
laughed along with
>> like you can even acknowledge that you think Ethan's
political takes or Israel takes are bad. You can you can hang
on to that. You don't need to abandon that. But all they had
to do was just say, "Hey, you know, like it's some of this is
going too far." Which it
>> But it wasn't going too far. Like what what was going
too far? What was going too far before he filed those lawsuits?
Hutch, I would say, you know what was going too far? It was the
campaign to get hit to get the Twitch CEO fired and to get Hassan
deplatformed. That was the campaign that went too far, right?
I would say if I had to say what went too far, it was probably
that campaign went a little too far. Not the not the comments
on Ethan. At least not from what I saw. What? It was basically
just people saying he was a Zionist. It was Brad Tasted Music,
right? Wasn't that who it was? Was it not Brad Taste of Music
who basically went to some event and then he posted a picture
of him and Ethan Neil Klein and then he took it down and that
turned into a whole drama. You guys remember that? That's like
what he's talking about. That's like the harassment or something.
It's totally deranged. Who cares? It obviously was. And they
didn't do that. They laughed along with the unhinged community
members that were taking it to such extraordinary extremes.
I I I think about like the somebody made an animated cartoon
of a murder.
>> Okay. The client supported the video creator after this
because he posted about Hassan. You can't make it up. You actually
can't make it up, man. Be like that though. People be like, "You
know what? Actually, maybe Hitler wasn't that bad cuz he hated
Hassan [__]
or some Okay. Some such. >> They were accusing her of doing
war crimes and insinuating that, you know, she was a valid target.
It was crazy. Just absolutely crazy. Oh, Hutchm info number 11.
Wrong.
You are wrong. You are lying. You are lying again. You are a
liar. [sighs] God.
This is
this is Cassan saying that the IDF soldiers in area B I think
would be valid military targets which also might not be true
but regardless was saying that even when Ela Klein herself went
into area B
right she would have been uh a valid military target when she
went on that raid to Rmula she would have been a valid military
target was never once excuse me never even close to saying that
Ela Klein was a valid military target in Los Angeles in the United
States in Israel as a civilian Nope. None of those times.
None of those >> Bumblin B with the primer. Thank you,
The CPS stuff was after like nine months of that. You know what
I mean? Like it's not the only factor here.
also I believe the Hassan Ela Klein comment is after CPS. So,
can we count that now? is Hutch missin info number 12 that he
just up the timeline on Hassan doing the Ela Klein possibly like
even your favorite influencers's wife which he was a IDF soldier
could have been when she went on that raid could have been a
valid military target that's actually Hutchiss info number 12
let's go so he's done two things that are explicitly not anything
to do with him filing the lawsuits and then what was the other
one it was
oh it was
it was CPS which is not was after the lawsuits are basically
planned it was Ela Klein the the butcher of Vermala that was
before before any of this and then the valid military target
which is way after. So none of the stuff he said. Is there was
there one? Was there one that applied? I thought there might
be one. Maybe like the insane harassment is calling them Zionist
by the way. That is the quote unquote insane harassment. That's
what they call that's what they talk about.
Skulls is closest. Skulls is after as well. Skulls is after he
planned the >> But it was a significant >> I think
is skulls not after. Skulls is after CPS, isn't it? CPS being
last week of February, first week of March. Skulls being end
of March, early April, right? mid- March, early Aprilation.
>> I would sayarily
have this video, that video. All right, I think I'm done with
that. If you're going to do a video covering a topic, at the
very least, you should look into what you're talking about, you
know? >> Dude, there's no way. Holy [__] Hutch
is a [__] My god, that's crazy,
dude.
Okay, well, that was fun, bro. How did he get IT SO WRONG? HE
GOT EVERYTHING so wrong that whole time.
Can you give me a 5-second overview of this specific drama? >> Sorry,
we're skipping forward on time stamps. We're going to go off
Hutch is going to go off on a tangent. We go to the last one.
Ethan announces a lawsuit against Idubbbz and Ana or is it just
Idubbbz? Uh, Moist Critical does a video covering
I think maybe he also covered the Denim stuff at the same time.
his position was not sufficiently anti-Ethan Klene enough. And
now Hassan is uh making a video complaining about that. This
bas >> Hassan's going to like painstaking effort to explain
to his audience why despite the fact that Moyes doesn't have
all the facts and doesn't quite present it like in a factual
way like
like why Moist includes some things that are contested as if
they're fact. The reason that happens is because of the space
he occupies. Hassan's gone through to try to explain that to
his audience. AND HUTCH SAYS HUTCH HASSAN JUST WANTS TO complain
that that Moyes isn't sufficiently on his side. >> Basically,
the TLDDR tweets in like the last two years. >> Yeah. I
don't I don't think he I don't Twitter as much any longer. I
think he just gets I I believe him when he says he gets his notes
from his audience and he gets his notes from like Reddit every
now and then or other content creators that reach out to him
and stuff. I do believe that [sighs] >> a bunch of >> dandoms
reacts to a clip of Ethan Klein saying this is all started because
I was not down with Hamas >> civilians. Your honor >> because
this all started. [snorts] >> It's true. >> I was
not down with Hamas.
>> Do you disavow Hamas?
Do you disavow Hamas? >> A bunch of civilians. I'm here.
>> True. That is literally true. That is
>> That's not true. >> That's what started it at
all. Actually, the cracks in the foundation formed when they
argued about capitalism versus socialism. It was then I knew
that that podcast was doomed.
But after October 7th, >> misinfo counter is lacking. Oh,
should I say that that's misinfo? These are like opinions. So,
I don't think of them as they're like opinions, but you know,
that probably could go up to 15 for that one that it's it's actually
just about Ethan Klein. It's and Ethan Klein. The only reason
people dislike Ethan Klein is because he said Hamas civilians
was bad. And the only reason Hassan is disliked is because he
argues for universal healthcare. Both of these things are equally
true. I believe both of these statements equally.
That was literally the reason that they started to have tension
and then that tension escalated into a conflict and then that
conflict escalated into a massive internet pylon. Your honor,
I had to sue all these people because everyone hated that I was
not okay with innocent civilians dying.
Hamas literally did this to me.
She's a vile human being, your honor. She's a vile human being.
>> I thought that was a bad thing.
And that's what started the entire, you know, chasm between me
and Hassan and the whole community. >> What? Like, yeah.
which is why I started suing every content creator around >> He
doesn't even deny it, you guys.
That's pretty funny. He doesn't even deny the framing that I
>> No, he does deny the framing. He doesn't take it seriously.
He's obviously denied the framing a thousand times.
Assan will say, "No, I was defending Ethan." He was objectively
defending Ethan and saying, "I know you personally, Ethan. I
know you're not like this, but some of the stuff you say, it
comes off a certain way, and you are responsible for that. I
need you to be better, too. I will help but I need you to be
better was the messaging from Assad. That's what it >> Suspect
has been friendly with Assan at any point. Um yeah, this is >> is
this H3 crew is tired? H is now openly questioning why Ethan
Klein is legal smoke for Idos but none for Destiny. Is Ethan
starting to lose support of his own crew? >> I don't know.
Is this count as smoke
>> Is he looking at a not chronic Sonic tweet? What the
hell? >> Destiny. So it's again it's just >> this
is why >> he unwittingly got sucked into the snark you're
talking about because our fans are chill. [snorts] It's all these
like >> that's crazy uh waiting uh for >> snarking
communities who are colluding all over social media everywhere
to put forward these narratives and I have no way to fight I
have no way to fight this title wave of [snorts] >> and
someone who's reasonable
>> what narrative what what what's the narrative they're
putting forward
what what is the narrative that's being put forward about Ethan
Klein that's not true. I I actually don't know where is the narrative
that's being put forward by all these starking communities about
Ethan Klein that's not true. I would love to do like a rapid
fire with somebody if they could just throw out which whichever
one of these like what which is a starker talking point that
is actually just untrue
cuz I know they're not the ones I say. I don't say a bunch of
about him that's >> Thoughtful like Charlie is now is like
>> First of all, his community is not chill. They've literally
like harassed the CEO of Twitch. Hey Dan, do you have any comment
on why you won't let Ethan Klein stream on your platform
[laughter] content nuke? >> Why he got banned twice? >> Uh,
it got reversed. >> Um, while he was calling me and everyone,
that is harassment. Is that >> I mean, I don't think so.
If I went up and asked Ethan and Ela Klein why they're going
vacationing in Israel, if I went and asked Ela Klein that in
person in in real life, would that be harassment? Hutch, hey,
why are you GOING TO WHY ARE YOU GOING TO VACATION IN ISRAEL
WHEN THERE'S A genocide going on, Ela? Don't you think there's
a genocide going on? Isn't it weird to go to Israel and show
them support support their economy?
I I feel like you would consider that harassment probably.
>> Maybe it's walking up to the line. I don't know. That's
harassment.
That was uh pro Palestine. >> It's crazy cuz nobody's
dude Hassan's community is
>> And I just want him to say what Hassan Hassan's community
has done for harassment. Where's the harassment from Hassan's
community? >> Brutal. I've said it once. I've said it a
million times.
His community, >> but you don't say what they've done.
>> Vicious from my perspective. Being on the receiving
end of his community
is brutal, man.
>> I have been on the receiving end from that community.
It is nothing. It is literally nothing. It is not a problem.
It's not even remotely bad.
I'm sorry. It's not bad. It's really not.
I've been on the receiving end from that community. Now, what
Hutch is doing here is he's probably adding in a bunch of communities
that aren't Hassans, that don't like Hassan, have basically never
liked Hassan, and maybe slightly aligned with him for a tiny
period after October 7th, right? Like he's going to include bad
empanada as a part of Hassan's community. Right.
And I'd say maybe I never got I never ran a foul of bad empanada,
so I don't know how that is. I've heard it's bad. Okay. But I've
definitely run a foul of Hassan's community. They've definitely
disliked me. No problems. Just for making fun of him and his
goofy his goofy idiosyncrasies.
Zero problems, nothing. >> They go absolutely ham.
A
is I had the Teddy Fresh rug behind my back and I literally was
oblivious to what he was saying. >> I just want Hutch to
say what the harassment is, right? He keeps saying they go crazy.
They go crazy.
I can't name very much harassment from them. They're like, "Oh,
you suck. Oh, you suck, man.
Oh, you're you're like a
Okay. And I'm not but like even if I was
and kept repeatedly defending him which was a massive mistake
in my opinion. >> Ethan is a mega Zionist. You are wrong.
Okay. Trust me I don't think you know. >> Okay. October
30th 2023
pushing back against this. How does Hutch react?
What I've seen from Hutch when he gets proof thrown back in his
face that he's wrong about something. He quite often just lets
it slide by it like basically he's like um
he's like infinite HP tank. Okay. He just gets hit directly.
Critical hit to the forehead, but he's got a million HP, so it
doesn't do anything to him and he just keeps trucking. Okay.
>> No. Uh I don't think you know many uh many Zionists
if you think Ethan is a mega Zionist.
>> This is wild. So he's implying that he was incorrect
to say this, but this is just objective. No, he's not.
Wait, hold on. I should actually go back. Maybe he was implying
that it was wrong he said this. I I would imagine he's not saying
it was wrong that he said it. I would imagine he's probably saying
something like I there was no reason for me to say it cuz he
obviously just kept going. >> Is brutal, man. oblivious
to what he I had the Teddy Fresh rug behind my back and I literally
was oblivious to what he was saying and and kept repeatedly defending
him, which was a massive mistake in my opinion. Ethan doesn't
>> Yeah, it's a mistake to defend him cuz he was being
[__] talked at this point, right? Like Ethan was
already shit-talking him, already working with the the campaign
that was going to try to get Hassan deplatformed, right? Maybe
not October 30th specifically, but up until this point, >> Zionist,
you are wrong, okay?
Trust me, I don't think you know uh I don't think you know many
uh many Zionists if you think Ethan is a mega Zionist. >> I
believe it's sometime in 2024 that Hassan breaks and stops defending
him. Right. Still came back and said the CPS call is unacceptable
from anybody. >> This is wild. So he's implying that he
was incorrect to say this, but this is just objectively true.
>> Like tactically incorrect. Tactically, >> we're
talking about mega Zionist Ethan and both Ethan and Ela. There's
no way that that label could ever >> Ethan. It doesn't
apply to Ethan. I'll give you it doesn't apply to Ethan. I'm
sorry. And listen, I don't want to snark Ela too much, but come
on. I I'm sorry. I will give you also that Ela grew up there
and that she is, you know,
I don't want to say,
oh, what do you say, dude? It's like he's like brainwashed. Okay,
we keep >> Reasonably be applied to them. >> Not
even close, dude. Time. >> But now he's implying that he
was that this was wrong. I guess they are mega Zionist. Time
again, I've spoken about how Ethan is not your enemy. A person
who cries when a Palestinian child dies is not your enemy.
Okay? He's not. I've said these exact words over and over again.
I told people, >> by the way, Hutch was arguing that this
was an insane harassment campaign from Hassan and his audience.
Insane harassment campaign from Hassan and his >> in this
community and people everywhere that will listen to what I have
to say that you have to choose who you are actually angry at.
There are people who are so loud and so proud. Was this before
or after they had the conversation
where Ethan was asking him to like do more about like his discord
specifically I think was particularly
>> When when was that conversation? I think it was pro
this is probably before >> he had to nuke his discord I
guess because they were just they were posting
>> didn't nuke his he nuked his discord because teachers
were logging his discord and like trying to pull up all messages
about Ethan Klein to start
I know cuz I got handed huge swaths of like images and that were
just crawls of his discord >> unhinged stuff about Ethan
>> just saying >> not the ethnic cleansing campaign
the Palestinians are are experiencing currently go yell at them
he's been on you on his members streams. I don't care. I don't
care.
Or literally shout on you yesterday and his co-orker for saying
from the river to the sea. Sorry, dog. I don't care.
I do not. Will Hutch react? Will Hut like Hutch is watching this?
I just hope you could tell he's looking for any way to make this
not matter, to make this like not a thing that he has to integrate
into his mind. To admit you were part of the Diddy G Snark machine.
Yeah, I was really good at it. Best day of Hassan's life is the
day that Desessie got outed for being the weird pervert he is
and I didn't want to hang out with him anymore. Okay? Because
I was way more effective than anybody else he had. Okay? I was
way more effective at this. I WAS GOOD AT THAT JOB
such that it was a job such that it was something to be you something
you could be good at. Okay? I was really good at it. Care
this is petty drama. Okay. I will always stand by
Ethan's ability to empathize and want to learn and want to change
his perspective. Okay, that's it. Ethan is my friend. I think
he's an empathetic person and I hope that that is clear. No one
like changing your perspective on an issue that is like near
and dear to your heart is virtually impossible. It's one of the
hardest things you can do. I will forever have respect for him
for doing that on his own. Okay. everything that people say cynically
he did to like win favors with the larger crowd that and you
need to as a community also stop ripping into Ethan nonstop
as I've said it over and over again leading up to the conversation
that we had on this broadcast. You guys are so stupid for doing
that. You are. And it frustrates me to no end. I've told you
this time and time again in this frame in this time. Like I said,
when I actually went through and watched like the clips back
and watched all of it, I'm like, "Oh,
I can see that Hassan is actually yeah, consistently cutting
against his audience in a way that doesn't help him." By the
way, Hassan lost a bunch of people from his audience like after
this, like it wasn't just H3 fans leaving. It was also a bunch
of lefties who were like, "Oh, this is too much, man. You defending
Ethan is too much." He he had like a huge falloff after octo
after October 7th in terms of viewers. time frame. Just like
I kept telling you, Ethan is not your enemy over and over again.
That's why I love love Idubbbz Ethan as well. People that have
actually changed course,
recognize their mistakes in the past and now advocate against
those sorts of things. >> She's on his phone or he's looking
something up in a browser. >> That's why I love Idubbbz.
Ethan as well. People that have actually changed
>> recognize their mistakes in the past, and now advocate
against those sorts of things, I think are very valuable because
every single person has, >> it's evolutionary perspective
deep down inside on on one issue. We are all totally susceptible
to the intersectionality of privilege. Privilege causes us to
have blind spots. Ethan is my friend. We may have disagreements
every now and then, but I have maintained the position that he
his heart is always in the right place and he's on a journey
of learning. Every single day, I went live in the beginning.
Every single day, I would spend at least 5 minutes to 30 minutes
talking about how Ethan is not your enemy. You should not yell
at Ethan. Ethan is a good person. Be more charitable to those
who are open and and susceptible to your opinions. >> Did
this nearly every stream. Meanwhile, Ethan was slandering Hassan
daily, calling him a terrorist supporter, etc. >> I I recognize
that now watching it just totally backed off. >> He was
a incredibly person.
>> That's crazy.
Where the did this Assan go?
>> I think Han would probably say that although he thinks
it was tactically wrong, he probably would say he doesn't even
disagree with what he was saying there. That's what he thought.
He thought it was reasonable to say that. Didn't realize, you
know, people were in Ethan's ear changing his mind on things.
It's just wild to me that Hutch got on his phone or started like
looking at his other monitor instead of paying attention to this
content. It's so obviously disingenuous. Like every time he wants
to talk about culty behavior, inroup in group facing behavior
or what did he call it? He called it um tribalism. He used tribalism.
Your tribe. Yes. He talked about that how like you can't accept
information. You won't look at the facts. And he's just gotten
something that cuts against every narrative he was spouting through
this entire video, through this entire stream.
And he is not paying attention. He doesn't want to see it. He
doesn't want to see it at